Soy la persona más afortunada del mundo.
Tuve la oportunidad de ver el último caso de viruela letal en el mundo.
Estuve en India el año pasado
y puede que haya visto el último caso de polio en el mundo.
No hay nada que te haga sentir más, la bendición y el honor
de trabajar en un programa como ese, que saber
que algo tan horrible ya no existe.
Así que, voy a decirles --(Aplausos)--
así que, voy a enseñarles algunas fotos impactantes.
Son duras de ver, pero deberían verlas con optimismo
porque el horror de estas fotos será contrastado
con saber que eso ya no existe.
Pero, primero voy a contarles un poco acerca de mi viaje.
Mi formación no es, exactamente, convencional
como podrían esperar.
Cuando era un interno en San Francisco,
supe acerca de un grupo de Nativos Americanos
que habían tomado la Isla de Alcatraz,
y de una Nativa Americana que quería dar a luz allí,
y ningún médico quería ir a ayudarla.
Yo fui a Alcatraz y viví en la isla durante varias semanas.
Ella dio a luz, yo la asistí, me fui de la isla,
volví a San Francisco y toda la prensa quería hablar conmigo
porque mis tres semanas en la isla me habían convertido en un experto en asuntos indígenas.
Aparecí en todos los programas de televisión.
Alguien me vio en televisión, me llamaron, y me preguntaron
si me gustaría actuar en una película interpretando un joven médico
de un grupo de estrellas de rock que viajaban en bus
desde San Francisco hasta Inglaterra. Y yo acepté,
y me convertí en el médico de una película horrorosa
titulada "Medicine Ball Caravan."
Ustedes saben de los 60,
o te subes al bus o no estás en el bus.
Yo estaba en el bus. Mi esposa y yo a los 37 años nos subimos al bus.
Nuestro viaje en bus nos llevó desde San Francisco hasta Londres.
Nos cambiamos de buses en el gran charco. De ahí, tomamos dos buses más
y manejamos a través de Turquía e Irán, Afganistán,
por el paso Khyber hacia Pakistán, como cualquier otro médico joven.
Estos somos nosotros en el paso Khyber y ese es nuestro bus.
Tuvimos algunas dificultades para sobrepasar el paso Khyber,
pero terminamos en la India.
Y, entonces, como todos los de nuestra generación,
fuimos a vivir a un monasterio himalayo.
(Risas)
Es igual que un programa de médico residente,
para aquellos de ustedes que estudien medicina.
Y estudiamos con un hombre sabio, un gurú llamado Karoli Baba,
que luego me dijo que me quitara el vestido,
me ponga un traje de tres piezas,
vaya a unirme a las Naciones Unidas como un diplomático
y trabaje para la Organización Mundial de la Salud.
E hizo una predicción escandalosa de que la viruela sería erradicada,
y de que este era el regalo de Dios a la humanidad
por el duro trabajo de científicos entregados.
Y esa predicción se hizo realidad, y esta pequeña niña es Rahima Banu,
y ella fue el último caso de viruela asesina en el mundo.
Y este documento es el certificado que la comisión mundial firmó
asegurando al mundo haber erradicado la primera enfermedad de la historia.
La clave para la erradicación de la viruela fue detección temprana, respuesta temprana
Les voy a pedir que lo repitan: detección temprana, respuesta temprana.
¿Pueden repetirlo?
Audiencia: Detección temprana, respuesta temprana.
Larry Brilliant: La viruela fue la peor enfermedad en la historia.
Mató a más personas que todas las guerras en la historia.
En el último siglo produjo 500 millones de muertes.
Más de dos --ya estás leyendo acerca de Larry Page,
alguien lee muy rápido. (Risas)
En el año en que Larry Page y Sergey Brin --
con quienes tengo un cierto afecto y una nueva afiliación --
en el año en que ellos nacieron,
dos millones de personas murieron de viruela.
Declaramos erradicada la viruela en 1980.
Esta es la diapositiva más importante que yo he visto en salud pública
porque te muestra que ser el más rico o el más fuerte,
ser rey o reina,
no te protegía de morir de viruela.
Nunca debemos dudar de que esto nos concierne a todos.
Pero, ver la viruela desde la perspectiva de un soberano
es asumir la perspectiva incorrecta.
Deberían verlo desde la perspectiva de una madre
observando cómo su hijo desarrolla esta enfermedad sin ser capaz de hacer algo.
Día uno, día dos, día tres, día cuatro, día cinco, día seis.
Eres madre y observas a tu hijo,
y en el día seis, ves pústulas que se endurecen.
Día siete: se ven las cicatrices clásicas de la umbilicación de la viruela.
Día ocho.
Y Al Gore dijo que la imagen más fotografiada del mundo,
la imagen que más se ha impreso en el mundo,
era la de la Tierra. Pero esto era en 1974,
y, desde ese momento, esta foto fue la foto
que más se imprimió,
porque nosotros imprimimos dos mil millones de copias de esta foto,
y las llevamos de mano a mano, puerta a puerta,
para mostrarla a la gente y preguntarles si tenían la viruela
porque ese era nuestro sistema de vigilancia. No teníamos Google,
no teníamos arañas web, no teníamos computadoras.
Para el día nueve, ustedes miran está foto y están horrorizados.
Yo miro esta foto y digo, "Gracias a Dios"
porque está claro que este es solamente un caso ordinario de viruela,
y sé que esta niño vivirá.
Y para el día trece, se están formando costras en las lesiones, sus párpados están inflamados,
pero ya se sabe que esta niño no tiene una infección secundaria.
Y para el día 20, a pesar de que tendrá cicatrices de por vida, vivirá.
Hay otros tipos de viruela que no son así.
Esta es la viruela confluente,
en la cual no hay lugar alguno en el cuerpo donde puedas poner un dedo
y no estar cubierto de lesiones.
Viruela plana, que mató al 100% de los que la padecieron.
Y viruela hemorrágica, la más cruel de todas,
que tenía una predilección por las mujeres embarazadas.
Yo probablemente haya tenido 50 mujeres que murieron. Todas tenían viruela hemorrágica.
Yo no he visto a nadie morir de ella sin ser una mujer embarazada.
En 1967 la OMS se embarcó en lo que era un impresionante programa
para erradicar una enfermedad.
En ese año había 34 países afectados por la viruela.
Para 1970, habíamos bajado a 18 países.
En 1974, habíamos bajado a 5 países.
Pero en ese año, la viruela explotó a lo largo de toda la India.
Y India fue el lugar donde la viruela libró su última batalla.
En 1974, India tenía una población de 600 millones.
Existen 21 lenguas en India,
que es como decir 21 países distintos.
Hay 20 millones de personas en las calles en todo momento, en buses
y trenes, caminando, 500 000 aldeas, 120 millones de hogares,
y ninguno de ellos quería reportar si habían tenido un caso de viruela en su casa
porque ellos creían que la viruela era la visita de una deidad,
Shitala Mata, la madre frío,
y estaba mal traer a extraños dentro de tu hogar
cuando una deidad está en casa. No había incentivo para reportar la viruela.
No solo era India la que tenía deidades de la viruela,
prevalecían alrededor de todo el mundo.
Así, la forma como erradicamos la viruela fue --las vacunaciones masivas no funcionarían.
Podías vacunar a todos en India,
pero un año más tarde habrán 21 millones de nuevos bebés,
que en esa época era la población de Canadá.
Simplemente no sería suficiente vacunar a todo el mundo.
Tenías que encontrar cada caso de viruela en el mundo
al mismo tiempo y dibujar un círculo de inmunidad alrededor de él.
Y eso fue lo que hicimos.
Solamente en India, mis 150 000 mejores amigos y yo
fuimos de puerta en puerta con la misma fotografía
a cada casa en la India. Hicimos más de mil millones de visitas.
Y en el proceso, aprendí algo muy importante.
Cada vez que hacíamos una búsqueda de casa en casa,
teníamos un pico en el número de reportes de viruela
Cuando no buscábamos, teníamos la ilusión de que no había enfermedad.
Cuando buscábamos, teníamos la ilusión de que había más enfermedad.
Un sistema de vigilancia era necesario
porque lo que necesitábamos era detección temprana y respuesta temprana.
Así, buscamos y buscamos, y encontramos
cada caso de viruela en India. Ofrecimos una recompensa.
Subimos la recompensa. Volvimos a subir la recompensa.
Teníamos una hoja de puntajes que escribíamos en cada casa.
Y, mientras hacíamos eso, el número de casos reportados en el mundo bajó a cero,
y en 1980 declaramos al mundo libre de viruela.
Fue la campaña más grande en la historia de las Naciones Unidas hasta la guerra de Iraq.
150 000 personas de todo el mundo,
médicos de todas las razas, religiones, culturas y naciones,
que pelearon lado a lado, hermanos y hermanas, uno con otro,
no uno contra otro, en una causa común de hacer un mundo mejor.
Pero la viruela fue la cuarta enfermedad que se pretendía erradicar.
Fallamos otras tres veces.
Fallamos en contra de la malaria, la fiebre amarilla y la frambesia (pian).
Pero puede que pronto veamos erradicado el polio.
Pero la clave para erradicar el polio es la detección temprana y la respuesta temprana.
Este podría ser el año que erradiquemos el polio --
eso la haría la segunda enfermedad en la Historia.
Y David Heymann, quién está viendo esto en el webcast --
David, sigue avanzando. Estamos cerca. Estamos en los últimos cuatro países.
(Aplausos)
Me siento como Hank Aaron. Barry Bonds puede reemplazarme en cualquier momento.
Saquemos otra enfermedad de la lista de cosas terribles de las que tenemos que preocuparnos.
Hace poco estuve en India trabajando en el programa contra el polio.
El programa de vigilancia contra el polio supone cuatro millones de personas yendo de puerta en puerta.
Ese es el sistema de vigilancia.
Pero necesitamos conseguir detección temprana, respuesta temprana.
Lo mismo con la ceguera. La clave para descubrir la ceguera
es hacer inspecciones epidemiológicas y encontrar las causas de la ceguera
para poder ofrecer un respuesta correcta.
La Fundación Seva la iniciaron un grupo de ex alumnos
del programa de erradicación de la viruela quienes
habiendo escalado la montaña más alta,
saborearon el elixir del éxito de haber erradicado una enfermedad,
y querían hacerlo de nuevo.
Y durante los últimos 27 años, los pogramas de Seva en 15 países
han devuelto la vista a más de dos millones de personas ciegas.
Seva se inició porque queríamos aplicar esas lecciones
de vigilancia y epidemiología
a algo que nadie consideraba
un problema de salud pública: la ceguera,
que hasta ese momento se había considerado solamente como una enfermedad clínica.
En 1980 Steve Jobs me dio esa computadora, que es la Apple número 12,
y todavía está en Kathmandu, y todavía está funcionando,
y deberíamos ir a conseguirla y subastarla para conseguir más dinero para Seva.
Y realizamos el primer estudio de la salud en Nepal,
y el primer estudio nacional de ceguera realizado en el mundo,
y tuvimos resultados sorprendentes.
En lugar de encontrar lo que pensábamos --
que la ceguera era causada en su mayoría por glaucoma y tracoma --
nos sorprendimos al encontrar que la ceguera era en realidad causada por cataratas.
No puedes curar o prevenir lo que no sabes que está ahí.
En sus paquetes de TED hay un DVD, "Visión Infinita"
sobre el Dr. V y el Hospital de la Vista de Aravind.
Espero que lo miren.
Aravind, que comenzó como un proyecto del Seva,
es ahora el mejor y más grande hospital de la vista del mundo.
Este año, ese hospital por sí solo, le devolverá la vista
a más de 300 000 personas en Tamil Nadu, India.
(Aplausos)
Gripe aviar. Yo me paro aquí como un representante de todas las cosas terribles --
esta podría ser la peor.
La clave para prevenir o mitigar una gripe aviar pandémica
es la detección temprana y la respuesta temprana.
No tendremos una vacuna o suministros suficientes de antivirales
para combatir la gripe aviar si ocurre en los próximos tres años.
La OMS establece niveles en el desarrollo de una pandemia.
En este momento estamos en el nivel tres en la escala de alerta pandémica,
con solo un poco de transmisión humano-a-humano,
pero sin transmisión sostenida de humano-a-humano-a-humano.
En el momento en que la OMS diga que nos hemos movido a la categoría cuatro,
esto no será como Katrina. El mundo como lo conocemos se detendrá.
No habrá aviones volando.
¿Te subirías a un avión con 250 personas que no conoces,
tosiendo y estornudando, cuando sabes que algunos de ellos
podrían portar una enfermedad que te podría matar,
para la cual no tienes drogas antivirales o vacunas?
Realicé un estudio de los epidemiólogos más importantes del mundo en octubre.
Les pregunté -- todos investigadores de la gripe y especialistas en gripe --
y les hice las preguntas que a ustedes les gustaría hacerles.
¿Cuál es la probabilidad de que haya una pandemia?
Si ocurre, ¿qué tan terrible cree que sea?
El 15% dijo que pensaban que habría una pandemia dentro de los próximos tres años.
Pero mucho peor que eso,
el 90% dijo que pensaba que habría una pandemia
durante la vida de sus hijos o sus nietos.
Y ellos pensaban que si había una pandemia,
mil millones de personas se enfermarían.
Y 165 millones morirían.
Habría una recesión y depresión global
mientras nuestro sistema de inventarios justo-a-tiempo
y el tenso elástico de la globalización se rompían,
y el costo para nuestra economía de uno a tres millones de millones de dólares
sería mucho peor para todos que los solamente 100 millones de muertos
porque mucha más gente perdería su trabajo
y sus beneficios de salud
que las consecuencias son casi impensables.
Y está empeorando, porque viajar está siendo cada vez mejor.
Déjenme mostrarles una simulación de cómo se ve una pandemia
para que sepamos de qué estamos hablando.
Asumamos, por ejemplo, que el primer caso ocurra en Asia del Sur.
Al inicio avanza lentamente.
Tienes dos o tres locaciones discretas.
Luego habrá brotes secundarios y la enfermedad se propagará
de país a país tan rápido que no sabrás qué te golpeó.
Dentro de tres semanas estará en todo el mundo.
Si tuviéramos un botón de deshacer y pudiéramos regresar y aislarlo
y detenerlo cuando recién comenzó. Si pudiéramos encontrarlo temprano
y tuviéramos detección temprana y respuesta temprana,
y pudiéramos poner a cada uno de esos virus en la cárcel --
esa es la única manera de lidiar con algo como una pandemia.
Y déjenme enseñarles por qué es eso.
Tenemos una broma. Esta es una curva de una epidemia y todos en medicina,
creo, finalmente llegan a saber qué es.
Pero la broma es, a un epidemiólogo le gusta llegar a una epidemia
justo aquí y montar hasta la gloria en la curva de bajada.
Pero uno generalmente no consigue eso.
Uno generalmente llega más o menos aquí.
Lo que realmente queremos es llegar aquí, para que podamos detener la pandemia.
Pero no siempre puedes hacer eso. Pero hay una organización
que ha podido encontrar una forma de conocer cuándo ocurre un primer caso,
y se llama GPHIN.
Es la Red Global de Información de Salud Pública.
Y esa simulación que les mostré y que pensaron que era gripe aviar,
era SARS. Y SARS es la pandemia que no ocurrió.
Y no ocurrió porque GPHIN supo ver la potencial pandemia de SARS
tres meses antes que la OMS lo anunciara,
y por eso pudimos detener la pandemia de SARS.
Y yo creo que le debemos nuestra gratitud a GPHIN y a Ron St. John,
quien espero esté en la audiencia en algún lugar -- ahí --
él es el fundador de GPHIN.
(Aplausos)
Hola Ron.
Y TED trajo a Ron desde Ottawa, donde GPHIN se encuentra
porque GPHIN no solo encontró el SARS temprano, sino
pueden haber visto la semana pasada que Irán anunció que tenían gripe aviar en Irán,
pero GPHIN encontró la gripe aviar en Irán no el 14 de febrero, sino en setiembre pasado.
Necesitamos un sistema de alerta temprana
que nos proteja de las cosas que constituyen la peor pesadilla de la humanidad.
Así, mi deseo TED está basado en el común denominador en estas experiencias.
Viruela -- detección temprana, respuesta temprana.
Cegera, polio -- detección temprana, respuesta temprana.
Gripe aviar pandémica -- detección temprana, respuesta temprana. Es una letanía.
Es tan obvio que nuestra única forma de lidiar con estas nuevas enfermedades
es encontrarlas temprano y matarlas antes de que se extiendan.
Así, mi deseo en TED es que ustedes ayuden a crear un sistema global,
un sistema de alerta temprana,
que nos proteja contra las peores pesadillas de la humanidad.
Y pensé llamarlo Early Detection (Detección Temprana)
pero debería llamarse Total Early Detection (Detección Temprana Total)
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero, hablando en serio --
como esta idea nació en TED,
me gustaría que sea un legado de TED y me gustaría llamarla
International System for Total Early Disease Detection (Sistema Internacional de Detección Temprana Total de Enfermedades)
Y INSTEDD se convierte en nuestro mantra.
Así, en lugar de tener una pandemia escondida de gripe aviar,
la encontramos e inmediatamente la contendremos.
En lugar de un novel virus causado por bio-terror o bio-error,
o cambio o deriva antigénicos, lo encontramos y lo contenemos.
En lugar de accidentes industriales como derrames de petróleo o la catástrofe en Bhopal,
los encontramos y respondemos a ellos.
En lugar de hambruna, escondida hasta que es demasiado tarde, la detectamos y respondemos.
Y en lugar de un sistema,
de propiedad del gobierno y escondido en las entrañas del gobierno,
construyamos un sistema de detección temprana
que esté disponible libremente para cualquier persona en el mundo en su idioma.
Hagámoslo transparente, no gubernamental,
que su dueño no sea ninguna sola compañía o país,
alojado en un país neutral, con copia de seguridad redundante
en un diferente huso horario y en un diferente continente,
y construyámoslo sobre GPHIN. Comencemos con GPHIN.
Aumentemos la cantidad de páginas web que revisa de 20 000 a 20 millones.
Aumentemos las lenguas en los que busca de siete a 70 o más.
Construyamos mensajes de confirmación de salida
usando mensajes de texto o SMS o mensajería instantánea
para averiguar de la gente que está dentro de 100 metros a la redonda acerca del rumor que escuchas
si es que es en verdad válido.
Y agreguemos confirmación por satélite.
Y agregaremos los sorprendentes gráficos de Gapminder en la información final.
Y creceremos como una fuerza moral en el mundo,
encontrando esas cosas terribles antes que alguien más sepa de ellas,
y mandándoles nuestra respuesta. Para que el próximo año,
en lugar de encontrarnos nosotros acá,
lamentándonos de cuántas cosas terribles hay en el mundo,
habremos trabajado juntos, usando las habilidades únicas
y la magia de esta comunidad,
y estaremos orgullosos de que hemos hecho todo lo posible para detener las pandemias,
otras catástrofes y cambiar el mundo, empezando ahora.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Una presentación sorprendente. Antes que nada,
para que todo el mundo lo entienda, tú dices que construyendo --
creando, arañas web, buscando patrones en Internet,
podemos detectar algo sospechoso antes que la OMS,
¿antes que alguien más pueda verlo?
Solo explícalo. Da un ejemplo de cómo se podría realizar.
Larry Brilliant: Antes que nada, ¿no estás molesto por las violaciones de los derechos de autor?
CA: No. Me encanta.
LB: Bueno, ustedes saben, como Ron St. John -- y espero que vayan y lo conozcan
luego en la cena y hablen con él --
Cuando empezó GPHIN en 1997, había un brote de gripe aviar.
H5N1. Era en Hong Kong. Y un notable médico en Hong Kong
respondió inmediatamente sacrificando 1.5 millones de pollos y otras aves,
y eso detuvo el avance del brote.
Detección inmediata, respuesta inmediata.
Luego algunos años pasaron
y habían muchos rumores acerca de la gripe aviar.
Ron y su equipo en Ottawa comenzaron a rastrear la red,
rastreando solamente 20 000 páginas distintas, sobretodo periódicos,
y leían y escuchaban acerca de una preocupación sobre mucho niños
que tenían altas fiebres y síntomas de gripe aviar.
Reportaron esto a la OMS. La OMS se demoró un poco en reaccionar
porque la OMS solo recibía reportes de un gobierno,
porque son las Naciones Unidas.
Pero lograron llegar a la OMS y hacerles saber
que había un sorprendente e inexplicable cúmulo de enfermedades
que parecían ser la gripe aviar.
Eso terminó siendo SARS.
Así fue como el mundo supo de SARS.
Y por eso fuimos capaces de detener SARS.
Ahora, lo que es realmente importante es que, antes de que existiera GPHIN,
el 100% de los reportes del mundo acerca de cosas malas --
aún si estás hablando de hambruna o si estás hablando de gripe aviar
o si estás hablando de Ébola --
100% de esos reportes venían de naciones.
En el momento en que esos tipos en Ottawa, con un presupuesto de 800 000 dólares al año,
comenzaron a trabajar, el 75% de los reportes en el mundo venía de GPHIN,
25% de los reportes en el mundo
venían de las otras 180 naciones.
Ahora, esto es lo realmente interesante,
luego de haber estado trabajando por un par de años,
¿qué creen que les pasó a esas naciones?
Se sintieron bastante estúpidos y empezaron a mandar sus reportes más temprano.
Ahora su porcentaje de los reportes ha bajado al 50%
porque otras naciones han comenzado a reportar.
Así que, ¿puedes encontrar enfermedades temprano rastreando la red?
Claro que sí. ¿Puedes encontrarlas todavía más temprano de lo que lo hace GPHIN ahora?
Claro que se puede. Ustedes vieron que encontraron SARS
usando una araña web china seis semanas completas
antes de que lo encontraran usando la araña web en inglés.
Bueno, ellos solo están rastreando en siete lenguas.
Estos virus malvados realmente no tiene intención alguna de aparecer
primero en inglés o español o francés.
(Risas)
Así que, sí, yo quiero tomar GPHIN, quiero construir sobre él,
yo quiero agregar todas las lenguas del mundo posibles,
yo quiero hacer esto abierto para todos
para que la autoridad de salud en Nairobi o en Patna, Bihar
tenga tanto acceso a él como los tipos en Ottawa o en la CDC,
y quiero hacerlo parte de nuestra cultura que exista una comunidad
de gente que está cuidándonos de las peores pesadillas de la humanidad,
y que es accesible por todos.